[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hero transitions
are a common UI pattern.
They let the user know
that they changed screens,
while keeping the focus of the
interaction front and center.
Flutter has the Hero widget.
It will automatically
create a Hero transition
between two navigator routes.
Flutter will figure out where
the widget is in both routes
and animate the change
between locations.
Let's say you want to use
a picture as your Hero.
Put it on both the page routes--
the one that you'll
be transitioning from
and the one you'll
be transitioning to.
Then, wrap the image with a
Hero widget on both pages.
Add a tag.
This can be any object.
The important thing is to use
the same tag on both pages
so that Flutter knows which
Hero we are animating.
And you're done.
For best results,
make the widget tree
below the Hero widget
identical on both screens.
Hero doesn't need to wrap
only images, of course.
Experiment with Clips for some
really cool animation effects.
For more info on Hero and
all the other widgets,
head to Flutter.io.
[MUSIC PLAYING]